NECESSARY.
AND SHOOTING THE THREE, BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT GOING IN, IT WILL
BE A LONG GAME.
>> GO AHEAD, KENNY.
>> WELL, IF THE BROOKLYN NETS
COULD WIN IT, IT'S 90 POINTS OR
LESS.
IF IT GOES OVER 90 AND IN TO THE
HUNDREDs, THEY CANNOT WIN.
JUST BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, YOU
JUST, YOU CAN'T GET OFF BASKETS
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE THE
PROFICIENCY THAT MILWAUKEE WILL
HAVE NOW.
WHEN KYRIE AND JAMES ARE OUT
THERE.
YOU WANT TO GET 100, 110
POSSESSIONS.
YOU WANT TO GET AS MANY
POSSESSIONS, WE TAKE 110, YOU
GET 110 WE ARE GOING BEAT YOU,
WE HAVE BETTER PLAYERS.
NOW WE HAVE TO SLOW IT DOWN AND
SAY, WHEN KEVIN DURANT IN THE
LAST FOUR MINUTES OF THE GAME,
IT'S 85-80, NOW HE CAN TAKE US
HOME.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO STILL GET
110, 112 POINTS YOU WILL NOT
BEAT THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS.
I CANNOT SEE THAT.
>> TO ME, THIS IS THE DEFINING
MOMENT OF THIS BUCKS TEAM.
THIS IS THE DEFINING MOMENT IN
MY OPINION.
THERE'S NO WAY, IF THEY -- LIKE
SHAQ SAID, UNLESS JOE HARRIS,
MIKE JAMES, AND BLAKE ARE DIVING
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
IT DON'T MATTER, THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TALENT TO BEAT THE BUCKS
TEAM.
IF I'M THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS I GET
TOGETHER WITH THE GUYS, THIS IS
OUR MOMENT.
AS LONG AS THEY DON'T OUT WORK
US, THEY CANNOT BEAT US.
THEY CAN'T SCORE ENOUGH POINTS.
IF THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS LOSE THE
SERIES WITHOUT JAMES HARDEN FOR
THE ENTIRE SERIES.
NOW, NO KYRIE, THIS THE WILL BE
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHOKE JOBS IN
BASKETBALL HISTORY.
HISTORY.
>> HISTORY.
>> YES, FOR HISTORY.
>> I'M WITH YOU ON THAT CHUCK.
>> I'M SERIOUS.
TO PLAY THE ENTIRE SERIES WITH
OUT JAMES AND BE 2-2 AND NO
JAMES AND KYRIE, IF YOU CANNOT
BEAT THE GUYS 2 OUT OF 3 GAMES
THIS WILL BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHOKE JOBS IN